DC Universe rebirth the biggest comics
event of a 21st century the greatest
heroes and villains some greatest
graphic novels the next epic starts here
vol 1 collections of the best-selling
comic book everyone we're back with
another stage demonstration here from
the DC University Art Academy and we
have uh we have art and Franco here yeah
we're happy response from the crowd yeah
yeah there you go thank you
oh so what it's what's up fellas
how's your Sunday oh it's awesome it's
like and Thursday we're taking a lot of
three days left and on Sundays they're
like ah so I say already you know I want
to keep going you know you should make
it another week long five more days no
more did nobody here are there any kids
out there because this is this would be
this would be your jam well there is a
small very small child in front of us
all right two years old
so what are you guys doing here we are
we're probably famous @bt for making
tiny Titans
that's right and I'm Emily adventurous
yeah powers a lot of different stuff yep
so we're going I'm going to draw a whole
bunch of characters awesome sure thank
you I'm going to see how many characters
I could draw in 15 minutes or so let's
do it
yeah so what are you starting on now
there's a Robin playing Peyton what's
good yeah that's their a mean round yeah
yeah oh yeah this is the way I draw at
home I draw on until of sketchbooks
every day and I just been drawing comics
since I'm a little kid and when BP asked
me to make tiny Titans I was thrilled I
didn't believe it was I thought it was a
prank phone call so Franco what are you
doing over there on the UM drawers and
drawers he's a lot faster than I am so
we just let him draw eventually we'll
see what you have yeah yeah we'll go
through the let's see what happens just
know that for every one drawing or every
five drawings he does I have like a half
one done okay all right well yeah good
scale here's a character I created for
DC Comics they didn't even know I
created until it was published like wait
a minute
he didn't exist before with characters
hollaback co-created tiny Titan comics
and now we actually have a little plus
column
yeah ow editor yes it's a well I've got
a plus I'll get a box of plushies that
deliver to my house on hold and I'll
keep back how in there but as cool bin
yeah right power to back I'm putting
hearts on there so things just a normal
cow who's worked out a lot why they're
hard to fight back now yes mark this
dippers Oh
there's another guy created for DC they
didn't even know this guy didn't exist
either his name is Robin Robin
how do you how do you I mean obviously
Robin Robin seems pretty logical but how
do you think about all how do you think
of all this stuff I don't know it sounds
like always in my head I probably have
something in my head right now then
that's going to come out later tonight
and also this is Robin Robin but I I
always think of the characters this is
all I know how to do like I would drive
trucks but I was never good at driving
trucks and all that stuff sweeping
floors with car tunings like tying my
shoes I'd do it every day
I'm from Chicago that slice it shoes
inside my shoes too specific its we love
to go we're going to go classic so
character from superpowers
you've got theme songs we got movie got
actors portraying him operative this guy
is specific
the superpowers on a food you guys read
superpowers
alright one guy that's awesome
so what kind of comments to read when
you were guys when you guys were kids
oh man I grew up on super trend doing a
lot of super friends from PCR
hanna-barbera Super Friends and yeah
well I'm always a classic guy I grew up
on our Batman Superman The Hulk and
spider-man and I loved it when he teamed
up I got the Superman Batman or Superman
spider-man team-up was that was the best
comic ever my mom bought it for me and
then two dollar cover price when comics
for like 35 cents on it was crazy but
superheroes I had those old cloth Mego
action figures with the cloth case oh
yeah let's take em up before Star Wars I
had all those I used to play with and
that was the first time I ever saw a
green arrow and and Aquaman was on TV
but I never had the green arrow before
and Mixel pedelec had actually figured
him crazy so I've been I've been I've
been into superheroes since I'm a little
kid and never went away now I get the
job of Superman of Bam and it's so weird
I would advise of the kids stick around
here we have ran out like 90 sketches
and about yeah three minutes no we have
to give away notice 20 because my dad
solved superpowers books I read the book
and he said it says well you've been
drawing comics all the time and you work
at a DC Comics when you finally get to
make Superman and Batman and Wonder
Woman in a comic it's like what are you
going to do now what else can you do
basically I don't know that I think I
made it I want to do more economics
please amaze you see this climb of in
the comic industry and finally you get
the Superman so what was your
inspiration for the superpowers book um
we just want to make justice played I
come we did that a Superman family and
we had so many stories we wrote like 50
issues of that and it only went to issue
12 but we started more stories to tell
so superpowers is actually a sequel to
Superman
Avengers but we included the whole
Justice League this time and and and
there was six issues and we still have
15 she's left itself oh we want to keep
making story and keep us keep our
showing DC Comics what what our stories
are so they keep liking them so we're
waiting to see what we could do
something next you know I already to
back over here so I could dance back
room I could draw again make them you
know I don't take you like it will take
it to bits
I'll make it a little older Sookie needs
one Franco what were you reading or
watching when you were a kid I was
watching you know Batman the the 56
diamond I grew up on that stuff again I
was a my intro to the comics but then
oil to superheroes but then the comics
was the Teen Titans and I had that issue
where Marv Wolfman and George Perez like
go looking for the Duke well the Teen
Titans go looking for the Doom Patrol
and then they don't find them and I and
I couldn't get the next issue because
the drugstore I wasn't aware of the
concept of monthly comics so I got one
issued oh my god what happens I went
back to the store and it wasn't there
and they said oh maybe next month but it
went next month and there were no issues
it was like ah so for 20 years I never
knew how that story ended a long lasting
scar yeah I think we found it one time
walking around here we found that issue
and you found the next one to come next
what do you think if he gets it though
you might just stop comics I mean that
just might be in my just one comment I
finally got it I don't have to do this
anymore
yeah it is true you another guy could
run our fire does be poison ones our
fire not all the characters in tiny
Titan
you know one time I know there's over
220 characters in tiny Titan because one
time um this little boy lost his
schedule again show and he wrote me a
letter
he was real said that he someone lofted
her stole it or even misplaced something
happened so I bought a sketchbook and I
wanted a little mini one and I drew on
every page I drew a character on every
page and I mailed it to him what a note
that you have to color them all but that
so I know the sooner it's one bait two
hundred twenty characters and Starfire
I'm a draw ravenson Raven
did he ever color them did he ever get
back to you on I don't know what
happened yeah
if this Pierce for collectors he
probably said don't touch it you know
what I yeah it's cool
usually I color with crayons with do you
really call my brown
yeah a convention yeah oh we got a table
down this role and small press and I
could color somebody's if you want maybe
depends
my arm hurts Esther now we're good it's
like weird it's like whenever I do
something else with my arms I'm
uncomfortable so I got to get back to
drawing and then and I have a sketchbook
in every room of my house
true I got one of my popular bedroom
right there it's curved to me now so I
personalize it you know specific but it
goes on a plane with me and when I'm on
the airplane I do a lot of stories try
to get all my ideas when when no one's
around or Raven kind of cool
I feel outside and I also make Superfest
books you guys read the Superfest
I do from Capstone's but I did a super
friend encyclopedia and their chapter
books and a few years ago these comics
asked me to redesign like 300 of their
DC characters so we can make this
encyclopedia and I do guys like Deadman
and invented his pet and stuff like that
so it's kind of cool I get the dru
Deadman Booster Gold and Blue Beetle all
these characters there's crypto it was
the new Blue Beetle the Jaime
yeah Jaime Reyes yeah
yeah I love them and it's all I want to
do for my wife I'm doing it right now so
it's kind of cool yeah I know you wanted
yeah yeah mom's doing all right you come
to a place for a weekend everybody tells
you where your stuff is
yeah and you just drawn the hold on
that's great the guys are looking at me
in the back row sub fellows right there
sister the i neva sorry go ahead go oh
you hear is there a dirty character you
haven't drawn at this point in your
books I don't know I don't know I didn't
draw a lot of the vertol guys vertical
guys get well they just got to do Patrol
I get it yeah yeah I don't know I do it
a lot of guys again I'm always drawn
something yeah he is I'd forget what the
pets are it's been a while but he has um
he's got something I forgot it
yeah he's got something with us I forget
shame on me the Joker has the Joker foot
she had a joker fish the Joker fish so
yeah I forgot what the Riddler host you
guys have like five minutes how many how
many do you think you can knock out in
five minutes we have a record experiment
yeah there's a Joker fish
he's one of my favorites I got the Joker
pet plushies in the mail and I'm like
what the to put this this thing there's
a kid Lee ho lying there terrifying
my kids were scared my wife was so what
is that thing since the Joker fish honey
so harmless because they he's in the
water all day I don't know how he could
hurt you he did it we did a story with
the Joker push one of those uh the
cartoon
now we did a some stuff for Cartoon
Network is bumpers in between the stuff
so the the Super Pets stuff is from us
you can look them up on YouTube and said
I need to speaking super fast
who's this his bench this is a green
lantern squirrel I messed up on his lake
looking at I'm going to make it longer
pea fix it but this is badge remember
the green lanten squirrels name was chip
and one of the stories chip got killed
by a yellow school bus we will not lend
the ring left to squirrel and fawn
another squirrel and a fine edge yeah
and I found out his name is felt like
this and Jeff Johnson told me how to
spell it
yeah he told me on and call me on a pony
it's like badger but badge you don't say
to juror part suspicious yeah it's a
little weird life John tells you in the
phone it cracked you better yeah this
character it's amazing
yeah we're pals sister surely our bosses
are sure yeah this is um common to super
Horse Comics superheroes is really
strange character because he has a whole
bunch of different origin stories and it
started out where he got cursed like
beating a beef he got cursed and put in
a horse body but he loved Supergirl but
he could have talked to her and tell her
so that was his curse he's a horse
Centauri got tougher character yeah
maybe our right to be a horse especially
if you got powers in a cape good playa
cape in an S shield their hat becoming
super pet yeah who else we got
how about cyborgs you know I like doing
our demos with you guys yeah that other
people you need to give them the hook
but oh my god I know this guy's cannot
finish in like five minutes or three
minutes here to finish in the next 20
seconds yes you do
did you have Jill up here she did one
drawing right yeah kind of nuts around
yeah okay it was spectacular but it was
one of those pretty terrific me and come
on anybody can use watercolor yeah take
a real pro to do 76 pitches in two
minutes
now she's awesome cyborg who else we got
it I don't know I'm running honestly all
right I got a hat more guys how about on
give some Aquaman love to a regular
artful in another Jason Momoa oh I could
do Jess from Milwaukee Aquaman is
operating the underwater pets this is
topo the octopus what is this headed
cleared oh it's so PO like Oh topo I
learned about topo the other day I did
not know existed
yeah Aquaman always does different kind
of underwater things going on people
serious Steve Orlando miraculously
called an hour trivia that's amazing I
don't know if opal is a boy or a girl I
think it's a boy remember I'm sure an
octopus
sorry can you draw a Harlequin Harlequin
yeah
so I started I had Mara that's going to
be mad there's Harley
we saw Jason Momoa yesterday walk by her
table and I think he put some of my sis
astral level
I was tender and I went home well what's
that just what I thought the level went
down got a fun walking bar
yeah just one he's so often looking and
so I think I'm about four days I should
be alright maybe a cup of coffe or days
I don't know give me more than four days
it might be I gotta get home and sleep
before you exactly
I got it not only that but I have to
sleep in the fortress of solitude
I guess we're you guys here yesterday
when the Justice League butcher yeah it
they walked past our table and then they
walk back and then the line they kept
the lane cuz the whole cast went by a
security guard walked past and then
walked back up and then he looked at me
goes figure the flash is a slow one and
he's the last guy
[Laughter]
and I love Mara I'm so glad she's in a
new movie I saw a picture of her for the
movie now it looks pretty good yeah she
she's awesome I make custom action
figures two of those classic seventeen
Eagle Claw saga and I'm we're going to
hurt right now I had a girl reroute that
hair she has real long hair she put
sparkles in it is looks cool at that art
guys are nerd you know now that she's
awesome
all right let's get a couple more in
here actually maybe we just finish up
this one and we can get some sketches
away oh yeah we'll hook you up at the
end yeah we'll make sure I don't bring
home any how much time we got
it's good we're done that's on yeah now
we're going right we could do another 30
bars if we got a few bit Frank on how
many do you have over there one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12
see I told your kitchen you keep it up
what you doing all right here I mean
there's a lot more than fall here but
you know that's fine
second place is also nice thanks for
rubbing it in you're welcome Fischer
this is Jason Momoa alchemy my favorite
part of that trailer is then hair flip
oh so cool that makes me want to move
even more
you've got an armory let me get it up
I'm gonna get back many things that
means things just some hairy chests
actually going on and then I get
distracted I just watch him draw two
because I get distracted because that I
just watched him drunk - it's been so
cold
what's almost as good as he doesn't
realize me I'm going to draw this guy
I'm going to go how did the kids say
just so retro vintage back in his aims
whatever they say now throwback yeah
throwback yeah throwback Thursday say I
should draw decisions for Thursday but
this is the guy he goes in knock truck
guys know this guy yes Pesci chief super
Frank and he's walking but I was drawing
on a necklace and like a shirt it looks
better okay gets big when he says that
works and he fights Giganta gonna give
him shorts cuz he needs them he's going
to go into water anything you don't know
no one he gets real big how do you guys
usually give always catches here do you
just can they say this the wonderful
people the crowd yet all right they're
going to go crazy but we love usually
let you do it so you can beat a bad day
okay cool
it's just this great to hear yeah man so
I got a bunch of sketches kids by kids
first
I see anybody with any facial hair ask
me first that's got dumb be real matters
well ok here's a freaking triggered
flash did you Robin of course there's
Batman there's crypto took man - he'll
get some Raven going on there another
Batman the Joker mr. Wayne and then
there's Harley Green Lantern mr. Keefe
boy and comfortable but I'm gonna pump
but I'm Supergirl you guys are awful
I think you're going to give you stuck
your invisible man he's awesome
it's pretty moving it again I keep
thinking that's an eyeful right there
the reporter everyone give it up her art
and Franco they're great you guys are
out of a pen yeah
come see us by our booth talk yeah
you